existen existen en varias partes del
mundo muchas veces no de manera
explícita no abiertamente pero las
formas de sumisión de horarios de formas
de pago son claramente formas de
esclavitud contemporáneas muchos países
las seguimos
viviendo y bueno es muy triste y muy
lamentable que siga sucediendo bueno la
trata de personas se da en varios países
de américa latina tiene que ver con
redes extensas de comercio que van
por distintos países hasta eeuu y muchos
de ellos hacia europa
la unesco tiene un proyecto que también
se preocupa por este tema pero digamos
el que se ha ocupado de dar a conocer
esta fecha y su importancia ha sido el
proyecto internacional la ruta del
esclavo
libertad patrimonio y resistencia